motorola c'est une marque que je connais
depuis je crois que je suis gamin c'est
une marque qui étaient là dans la
téléphonie mobile est une marque très
forte sur le téléphone mobile avant le
smartphone et qui se voient reconnaître
a eu un peu de mal avec le virage des
smartphones mais qui aujourd hui en tout
cas est toujours là soit dans la course
et vient de sortir en 2019 un nouveau
smartphone c'est le motorola one by
jaune vous emmener le jour avec moi à
paris pour le découvrir sur une péniche
était plutôt pas mal et le temps est
venu aujourd'hui de vous dire ce que
j'en pense de vous donner mon retour
complet sur ce smartphone est ce qu'il
vaut le coup oui non quoi comment tout
ça on se regarde maintenant
[Musique]
voilà le smartphone comme il vous arrive
lorsqu'il sort de sa jolie boîte avec
une coque lors ça c'est plutôt bien que
motorola ils pensaient nous mettre une
coque transparente pour le protéger ça
va dans le bon sens je trouve pas ça
parfait mais en tout cas c'est bien
qu'il soit dans cette boîte
alors après le smartphone en lui-même
est assez standard il n'ya pas
complètement vous surprendre d'autre à
dire ce qu'il est capable de faire ou
néanmoins il est un format cas c'est
sympa
ce qui est vraiment à la pause tout
c'est ce format d'écran 21/9 il est très
allongée c'est assez pratique bien pour
la prise en main il faut par contre
utiliser à demain pour venir à utiliser
le haut de l'écran parce que sinon vous
n'allez pas y arriver avec une seule
main parce qu'il est quand même à zéro
mais par contre pour la prise en main
sans accès confort parce que on a quand
même un format qui est assez fun et ça
j'aime bien et je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant
le 29e c'est le format cinéma c'est le
format original c'est format cinémascope
tel qu'on l'a au cinéma donc c'est vrai
que ça format allongé et ça c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment cool le
smartphone en lui-même après et bien
mais n'est pas non plus exceptionnel
vous allez retrouver un de plastique
capteur d'empreinte digitale au centre
qui est pas fou mais ce qui est bien en
tout cas c'est d'avoir son petit logo
motorola donc ça vient l'habiller on a
un dock abdé incurvé que tu es plutôt
bien cuba ou fumée qui marche bien le
bouton ici sur le côté bouton de volume
bouton pour éviter postale c'est un
grand classique haut parleur mono de la
recherche d'angers bc ici votre micro
pour passer vos appels
ici vous avez votre lecteur de carte sim
double slim plus une carte micro sd
prise jack
si bien micro réduction de bruit et
voyais on a fait le tour le smartphone
lui-même est pas complètement dingue
mais est plutôt bien ce qui est bien
aussi c'est le capteur d'empreintes
digitales qu'il est les rouilles
extrêmement rapidement ce quelque chose
à ces standards assez classique mais ça
fait toujours son effet ça c'est bien
après le point qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est l'écran vous avez une
dalle ipes c'est du scd 6,3 pouces de
diagonale de 1520 par 1080 pixels cdu
fhd plus ça marche bien
le format est cool et vous n'êtes plus
qu'intéressant ce format cinémascope
après les trucs que j'ai un petit peu
moins aimé ces sept ans coach là non pas
parce que c'est une encoche plate forme
et parce que je trouve un peu grande un
peu large et on la voit beaucoup et
c'est vrai que je trouve que dans le
design c'est pas quelque chose
d'exceptionnel après c'est pas non plus
hyper grave ça évite d'avoir une encoche
mais cinq petites roues perforées la
bombe un jeu toujours un petit peu un
petit peu mitigé à côté de ça il faut
quand même avoir conscience qu'on est
sur un smartphone qui est pas hyper cher
on est sur un smartphone à 319 euros
tu as vu 99 centimes par un peu moins
cher ailleurs si vous intéresse devenus
tous les liens en bas dans la
description il faut donc reconnaître
qu'avec ce smartphone vous en avez pour
votre argent on l'a donc une expérience
globale qui est plutôt honnête au niveau
de l'écran mais malgré tout je trouve
quand même quelques petits défauts je
trouve quand même que globalement
c'était cran tire beaucoup trop bas bleu
est ce que je vous conseille à minima ce
venir dans vos réglages d'affichage vous
avez quelques petits réglages qui soit
intéressant vous allez dans l'éclairage
nocturne
je vous conseille de l'activer en
permanence alors vous ne mettez pas à
fond sans quoi vous aurez un tout qui
serait vraiment horrible et regardez là
c'est quand même assez bleus vous venez
légèrement le casser ça va lui donner
une touche un petit peu entre le jeune
et le rosé c'est pas exceptionnel mais
c'est toujours moindre mal parce que
vous pouvez pas venir régler ça sinon
après ce que je vous conseille de venir
dans les couleurs moi j'ai mis aux
couleurs contrastées par défaut il sera
en saturer je le trouve un petit peu
trop saturé au niveau des couleurs et
couleurs naturelles sont beaucoup trop
fade vous mettez en contrastes et ça
vous donne un peu plus de tonus un peu
plus de pêche à vos images sans aller
dans l'excès mais pour moi vous avez un
équilibre qui est pas mal
à côté de ça c'est un écran qui est
assez lumineux sans l'aide beaucoup trop
j'aurais aimé qu'on est un peu plus de
réglages un peu plus de possibilités
dans les réglages de l'affichage mais je
vous dis déjà avec ses deux
manipulations
vous avez quand même venir corriger
quelques problèmes majeurs au niveau de
l'audio vous avez du haut parleur mono
qui est quand même douce on les ya pas
un voulu qu est complètement dingue
à côté de ça le spectre est pas non plus
horrible on a quelque chose qui est
assez cohérent si vous voulez on reste
sur un smartphone un peu moins de 300
euros donc pas pas à s'attendre à voir
des haut parleurs stéréo dessus votre
haut parleur mono aussi sur le côté ne
crache pas énormément il n'est pas
complètement dingue mais il fera la
faire si vous optez dans une pièce où il
n'ya pas de bruit si par contre c'est
dans un environnement bruyant ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué ce que je vous
conseille à ce moment là c'est le choper
des écouteurs parce que oui vous avez
une prise jack sont en dessous je
voulais montrer sas est plutôt bien
pourquoi est-ce que des constructeurs
laissent des prises jack sur des
smartphones dans ce segment de prix tout
simplement parce qu'ils partent du
principe que sur mes 320 euros sur un
smartphone va pas forcément mettre 100
200 300 euros de plus sur un casque
bluetooth
donc il voulait une prise directe vous
avez vous écouteurs qui sont livrés avec
ce qui permettra d'écouteurs la qualité
d'un prêtre diakité écouteurs qui sont
friands la boîte je vous conseille quand
même d'acheter un petit casque en plus
ce n'est plutôt pas mauvaise qualité
ça sera bien le signal est cohérent et
correct vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
puissance vous n'allez pas profiter
d'une expérience type optimale dans les
environnements pro bruit
en d'un autre côté quand ya beaucoup de
bruit que vous mettez à fond castres
s'est pas non plus terrible les
performances sont assez correct ce qui
est très drôle c'est quand on trouve un
processeur samsung est d'ailleurs c'est
un exynos 9600 neuf couples est à 4
gigas de ram vous avez 128 go de
stockage extensible grâce à une carte
microsd jusqu'à 512 giga je trouve que
c'est vraiment correct c'est honnête on
a assez de fluidité pour vos usages
courants les usages classiques et même
pour jouer à des jeux peut même faire
tourner le pdg dessus avec un affichage
basse résolution mais ça marche c'est
bien ça lag pas particulièrement c'est
assez efficace donc de ce point de vue
là c'est bien et après l'autonomie est
assez sympa avec une batterie de 3500
milan perd heures vous avez un jour un
jour et demi d'autonomie en fonction
bien évidemment de vos usages saas
écoulant plus à vis de la recharge
rapide 15 watts en usb c'est qui vous
permet lorsque vous avez pas beaucoup de
temps il faisait loin de lui mettre une
petite charge voulu mettre un petit peu
de recharge est reparti ça c'est plutôt
bien
le s et bien c'est android one ça marche
parfaitement maîtrisée donc ça c'est
aussi plutôt cool mais la partie la plus
intéressante et qui est mise en avant
par la marque c'est la partie photo vous
avez un double module photo arrière vous
avez un capteur de 48 mégapixels c'est
le capteur de samsung qui vous permettra
de sortir des photos en 12 mégapixels en
rouge les 34 pixels vous faire un seul
d'année pour fixer pour capter plus de
lumière et optimisez vos photos en
photos de nuit c'est en tout cas les
promesses qui sont faites sur le papier
vous avez une ouverture de f
1.7 et vous avez un deuxième capteur
avec il a bien travaillé pour le mode
portrait et un capteur de 5 mégapixels
voilà ce qu'on peut faire
vous avez bien évidemment de
l'intelligence artificielle pour la
reconnaissance de celle de
reconnaissance de visages détection de
sourire pour déclencher la photo vous
avez bien évidemment de l'ia derrière
pour le menu enfin il ya pas mal de
petites possibilités donc ça c'est
plutôt cool et l avant vous avez un
capteur de 25 méga pixels qui est caché
leur second on voit parfaitement bien au
milieu et qui ouvre à f 2.0 vous
retrouvez également la même chose
c'est-à-dire la technologie ka pixels en
sortir iphoto de 6 mégapixels
ok et bien croyez le ou non ce
smartphone ce fait le taf au niveau des
photos je trouve que le gros point
positif est le gros point fort c'est
sous l'oeil des photos qui sont naturels
pas sursaturé tout est juste et ça c'est
vraiment ce qui me plaît et ce que
j'aime alors les photos sont pas non
plus complètement dingue mais la mise au
point s'est très rapidement elle en est
sûre le capteur arrière je pense que
vous serez douter sur le poteau donc en
12 mégapixels qui a pris par le capteur
48 milliards et celle de samsung ça
marche bien on a un rendu qui est
vraiment hyper cali de troyes s'est fait
très rapidement sur les feuilles en
alléger foudre hier plan mais ça marche
sur les couleurs sont très naturels et
c'est pour moi tout le
point positif de ce smartphone je dois
bien reconnaître les pierres ça marche
bien c'est vraiment maîtriser c'est
vraiment bien pareil
les couleurs sont très justes on aime le
petit avec les petites fourmis la fepaci
vous les voyez qu'ils sont en train de
se promener donc on récupère quand même
du détail
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant g3
effet automatiquement sur les pissenlits
donc c'est pareil c'est extrêmement
facile pour prendre des photos sur des
petits objets comme ça c'est que j'ai un
pareil pour cette fleur la même chose
ici je trouve ça vraiment bien après
vous avez une gestion du ciel qui est
pas complètement parfaite ici pourtant
vous avez bien le hdr qui est activée on
devine un peu les nuages
bon alors les sur un smartphone non plus
qui je vous dis une fois de plus à moins
de 300 euros on va pas attendre des
miracles
la caméra de celle ci on la retrouve et
d'écouté pour voir coller sur les
poteaux qui sort en 6 mégapixels
je trouve que le boulot est quand même
plutôt bien fait le rendu est très
honnête c'est tout ce qui est bien pour
une fois c'est que ce n'est pas
particulièrement lycée alors ça ne me
valorise pas j'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir 18 ans mais par contre on est
dans le vrai et ça ça me plaît et le
mode portrait marche aussi parfaitement
bien vous choisissez votre niveau de
blur votre niveau de flou il ya un beau
détourage qui est fait regardez là au
niveau des doigts alors là légèrement
ici il a eu un petit peu de mal mais
c'est vraiment pas grand chose on n'est
pas non plus sur un socle hyper
performant il est perdu des petites
feuilles si au passage mais ça me paraît
complètement normal vu la machine qu'on
a ici le détourage se fait plutôt bien
même entre les doigts il a un peu de mal
on va peut-être d'un côté de blanc mais
prouve que dans l'absolu un des sites ou
bien des tours et il ya un beau boulot
ici là c'est légèrement un petit peu en
dessous mais dans l'absolu pour voir
qu'on n'est pas sur le socle le plus
performant pour voir qu'on n'a pas le
smartphone le plus performant et bien le
boulot est franchement très honnête
maintenant pour voir qu'un gros focus
qui est fait au niveau de la caméra ne
trouve que c'est pas exceptionnel alors
moi je lui en veux pas je le pardonner
je comprends parfaitement tourner une
fois de plus vu le placement se produit
et vu le prix on va pas se rendre à part
à tout qui est exceptionnel mais
pourtant il ya un gros focus qui a été
fait là dessus par motorola sur le fait
d'avoir un one visionnent alors bon ça
fait le tard là il n'y a pas de lumière
dans la pièce je tiens vraiment à vous
le dire ça vous sort quand même quelque
chose qui n'est pas dégueu mais malgré
tout vous récupérer beaucoup de bruit ce
qui me paraît quand même dans l'absolu
complètement normale je le tiper
transparent pour moi ce smartphone
il se démarque pas dans un
un point particulier il est pas
exceptionnel d'un côté on va pas se dire
que la lie il a un écran qui est au
dessus de la norme vu son positionnement
il ya un appareil photo qui est au
dessus là non c'est pas vrai pourquoi ce
qu'il fait il le fait vachement bien et
c'est vraiment intéressant
j'aime beaucoup le parti pris de
l'étrange interne 9e ça se développe de
plus en plus on l'a vu avec sony xperia
one autres appareils d'ici quelques
jours l'xperia tm 10 on peut le faire à
la française c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant parce qu'on est vraiment
très proche du format cinéma et pour
tous ceux qui aiment justement de
regarder des films c'est vraiment bien
vous avez des films et des séries sont
disponibles sur youtube sans netflix et
sur votre plateforme justement avec ce
format 21/9 donc c'est vraiment plus
immersif et ça j'adore ça vraiment bien
la vitesse à l'écran est pas ouf
mais il fait le taff lo'jo et pas haut
mais ça fait le taff par contre ce qui
fait qu'il est vraiment cool
c'est la partie photo c'est un
smartphone qui est linéaire qui est
cohérent qui est bien mais qui manque
peut-être un peu de tempérament pour que
tout le monde sait ça maintient ce
motorola huawei vision il me le faut il
a ça qui est vraiment au top et il me le
faut
il lui manque un peu de personnalité à
côté de ça ce qu'il fait il le fait très
bien il est vraiment bien être moins de
320 drôle si vous serez pas déçus être
quelques promos d'ailleurs on peut le
trouver un peu moins cher en ce moment
d'ailleurs vous êtes le lien en bas dans
la description
moi je trouve bien je trouve que
motorola fait un produit qui est honnête
qui cohérent qui est bien et qui va dans
le bon sens et qui va pouvoir continuer
à proposer de produits plus intéressant
dans les temps à venir donc je vous
propose de rester connectés de regarder
de vous abonner comme ça vous saurez
tout motorola est plutôt bonne
progression de mai le début 2019 pouvoir
investir
donc je pense qu'on va avoir des trucs
bien dans les temps à venir donc
abonnez-vous comme ça on va reparler
ensemble a fait des gros becs vous
invite à me poser toutes vos questions
suggestions interrogations tout ce que
vous voulez en bas et puis vous rendez
vous demain et bisontin
[Musique]